the jurgen experience you look like
you've lost a large child from your body
86 pounds
that's right that's a large child i know
that you want to take credit for it
because fat shaming works exactly but i
can't give you all the credit no you you
deserve all the credit i didn't do
anything so because
i just was concerned for your well-being
and so i was just saying
if you really are saying that you want
to get healthy and you really are saying
that you want to play soccer and do all
these things again like a friend has to
be brutally honest with you yeah well
that's a hard one
that's a hard one because nobody wants
to hear they're gaining weight or
they've gained weight or that they have
to make radical changes to their life
i'm actually at the lowest weight since
i think 88. that's incredible size waist
33. how much better do you feel
phenomenal outrageous isn't it
incredible like if they could give you
that in a pill just the feeling how it
feels to be 86 pounds lighter exactly oh
my god i mean just to give you a sense
so that we could put it into metrics
when i was overweight our lovemaking
session was only an hour and a half
whereas now i've doubled it
congratulations oh thank you how do you
have so much time
it's incredible it's my wife is lebanese
she's spicy she demands a lot of me what
did you do uh other than exercise and
like what like how did you shift your
diet so
two things
number one
fifteen to twenty thousand steps a day
no matter what no matter what so it's
been almost now two and a half years
that i haven't done a single day of less
than ten thousand steps now the steps
could be treadmill it could be walking
outside it could be running vigorously
on the you know out whatever it could be
biking but i always have with me that's
actually at fault is it one of those
pedometers these are the speedometer
things and uh i'm obsessive about
maintaining so just by having this clear
objective that i have to reach makes it
that no matter what i've got to get off
you know off the
proverbial couch and walk around it's
minus 20 in montreal i'm walking outside
until i reach wow so that's but i was
always quite physically active of course
much of your weight loss comes from
keeping this guy closed yeah that's the
thing that people need to re it's very
very very very difficult to exercise
your way to weight loss exactly and so
what i did uh so my wife who's here who
you've known her for many years she's a
amazing woman she
turned into the diet gestapo
she's got she's got this my fitness pal
they're getting i guess free publicity
on the number one show in the world so
through my fitness pal she would she
enters till today every single thing
that goes into this gorgeous body wow so
at the end of the day she says don't
have any snacks you're at 17 27 and you
were supposed to get under 1700. so by
having that uh
feedback loop that's always keeping you
in check plus the so the third thing
is i weigh myself once a week
so that the autocorrective mechanism
comes in not when i've now when i'm now
227 in terms of weight but if i've come
to texas and then i go on the scale and
i've gained three pounds well now i need
i know that i need to
correct the following week so these
little changes i mean there's nothing
magical just doing that
i guess if i can add a fourth thing i
removed the all or nothing mindset in
the past i mean i the highest weight i
reached joe can you and you won't offend
me can you from from knowing me for many
years do you know how heavy i got i
guess you can calculate well if i look
at you now you look like you weigh about
a hundred and sixty-five pounds
i'm 170. ah see you i'm one so very good
i'm good at weight classes a lot of
years exactly um
and i would imagine the heaviest you got
was probably close to 300 pounds 256.
yeah okay so that's the 86 pounds so 256
for that's the heaviest that's the
heaviest that i maybe i could have been
more that i'm aware of that i've
actually seen it on the scale was 256 i
had gone from my yearly physical and i
got on the scale and i was 256 which is
the average weight for a six foot four
middle linebacker yeah just you know
yeah eight inches taller yeah
that's scary and so
so i removed the all or nothing mindset
and that i need to lose all the weight
by next tuesday you know my mindset was
as long as every day i'm a bit better
eventually you know the old baby steps
there and so i get on i'm now 10 pounds
less 20 hey let me try to get under 200.
i am
and then bit by bit magically here i am
for a message if you have a message to
anybody out there that's trying to do it
what would it be what's the most
important thing it's that there are 1
000 different temptations in a day for
you to violate your goal
and you can almost never fail you don't
have to be so punishing but
997 out of the 1000
bifurcations in the road you have to
take the right road and so do that
enough days enough times get 997 out of
a thousand and suddenly you'll be 30 40
50 pounds later just trust the process
trust the process and that's that's
what's hard for people to do because
they really do want immediate results
and uh the way i always describe it
there's a there's a gambling term that
you have to get better the same way you
get sick it's like uh if you're gambling
say if you and i were playing pool and i
was ahead 100 games and you said double
or nothing i would say no no no you got
to get better the same way you got sick
right because i'm up 100 games why would
i get why would i risk losing it all in
one one shot no no no
yeah and that's that's how it is with
weight loss you got to get better the
same way you got sick slowly over time
and it's been now
you know the the usual thing is that you
put it back on uh i've now helped you
know had it off for for for quite a
while so i'd like to think that i'm in
my steady state now but well you've
become aware now of the value of being
thin and healthy and you've become aware
of how good it you feel yeah i don't
think you're a smart man you're not
going to go back exactly have you did
you ever have any trouble with your
weight i mean i've been like five pounds
overweight before 10 pounds overweight
that's it yeah and then i always like oh
you fat [ __ ] and i lose the weight now
is that is that because of your
body
no no not putting on why didn't you ever
put on more weight
it's not an option
i'm not getting fat is it is it
literally a vanity issue uh no it's a
health issue i work out i do martial
arts if i'm fat i can't it can't work
out like if i can i i feel it it's like
i put sludge in my engine yeah you know
like the fattest i ever got i think i
got to like 207
one time and it's for me it goes right
here goes on my sides and in my belly
and it was also was eating a lot pasta
which is just not for me
whenever i do that i always feel like
[ __ ] and uh i just overeat
but i work out a lot so it keeps it in
check for the most part but i can get it
it can get away from me if i'm stupid
because i just uh i still eat like a
teenager i eat like i eat as much as i
want like i eat large amounts of food
but you do mainly the protein stuff
right yes mainly mainly i eat meat but i
eat mostly meat and fish and fruit
that's mostly what i do so i guess the
fifth element of when you asked me what
how do i lose weight i also removed all
the carbs almost all of it once in a
while i you know i have a bit of
something but so what is a daily meal
for you like so breakfast i may have one
or two boiled eggs
lunch might be my wife and i go to the
peruvian rotisserie place that we
probably go to four times in a week
which i'll get a quarter of a chicken
with a bit of coleslaw vinegar coastal
not creamy coleslaw
i might have one or two snacks around
mid-afternoon which might be things like
100 grams of frozen raspberries
a little yogurt of 70 calories and then
dinner will be a fantastic salad that if
you looked at the volume you think my
god how are you losing so much weight
but it only has you know five six ounces
of protein but it's voluminous so that i
feel full i may have another
you know a little snack at eight o'clock
70 80 calories and i've reached my 15 16
1700 calories
you